et nous ça nous en compagnie de louis
keumayou président du club de
l'information africaine et abdelkrim ben
yacoub koundougou me chercheur associé
au groupe afrique de lits pse bonsoir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous ce soir
sur rtl france parmi les membres de
cette ligue arabe l'arabie saoudite et
les émirats qui se sont jointes ou deux
aux américains pour faire pression sur
les militaires dans un communiqué commun
ils appellent donc le général al burana
la restauration immédiate du
gouvernement civil qu'elle peut être
l'influencé de l'arabie saoudite et des
émirats sur les militaires sous dernière
décrit mme aya cool cool de ruby
il ne faut pas s'attendre à grand chose
ou d'un pack étant donné qu'aujourd'hui
on va très bien que la ligue arabe est
une organisation qui n'est pas uni et
qui n'a pas une stratégie d'action
commune et quand on voit le pli de la
ligue arabe qui est l'egypte dont le
général kissi et le président et qui ait
le soutien principal de goran
aujourd'hui l'egypte et beaucoup de pays
de la ligue arabe souhaite que lier les
régimes militaires fort au soudan et
donc il ne faut pas se leurrer et quand
on voit la réaction de la ligue arabe
qui n'a pas condamné le coup d'état
l'union africaine n'a pas condamné le
coup d'état l'organisation de la
coopération islamique n'ont pas condamné
le coup d'état ils ont juste dit qu'ils
étaient préoccupés de la situation vous
été inquiet c'est la montre très bien
l'influencé de l'egypte allait lever tôt
que le président égyptien a posé au sein
de toutes ces organisations pour
empêcher une condamnation ou une
suspension de sedan suite à ce coup
d'état donc aujourd'hui la ligue arabe
peut venir et jouer sa partition mais je
ne vois pas très bien comment ces munich
pourrait imposer à elles seules des
sanctions pour obliger ces militaires
qui sont ses alliées a changé des
positions vous partager ce constat louis
keumayou quel rôle joue selon vous
l'egypte dans la situation au soudan
aujourd'hui
l'egypte joue un rôle qui est très
important parce que l'egypte est le
modèle sur lequel de mon point de vue
aujourd'hui les militaires soudanais
sont elles lors des marches il ya eu une
élection présidentielle en egypte si
ceux ci qui a été suivi par le
renversement des militaires td du
président élu par les visiteurs et cela
a été mollement condamné par l'union
africaine et par le reste des
institutions et puis la ligue arabe son
siège et il est en egypte donc tous ces
pays là se prononceront mais le soudan
est aujourd'hui dans une position qui
peut à certains quoi ressemblait à celle
du zimbabwe un peu plus bas parce que
c'est implique exporte énormément de
choses notamment vers le golfe ce qui
fait que ces pays ont besoin du soudan
pour continuer d'être alimentés
notamment sur le plan ii des produits
alimentaires et donc pour ça je pense
que la pression ne sera pas fort qu'une
autre élément qui entre également en
ligne de compte par rapport à cela c'est
que le soudan a soutenu l'arabie
saoudite dans la guerre au yémen et donc
tous ces appuis mis ensemble montre bien
qu quoi qu'il advienne aujourd'hui on va
condamné du bout des lèvres et les
militaires savent que les coups d'état
sont aujourd'hui de plus en plus tolérer
que ce soit sur le sol africain ou en
birmanie comme on l'a vu avec les
militaires birmans il ya une
condamnation du bout des lèvres puis à
une espèce de quasi normalisation tout
ce qu'on peut espérer c'est que la crème
par exemple d'être traduit devant la
justice internationale
reste que ces militaires n'est pas dans
une escale est où ils tireront à balles
réelles et où ils tueront beaucoup de
civils c'est la seule chose aujourd'hui
qui peut être redouté mais sur
l'ensemble je partage
qui a été fait avant alors autres
institutions à un verre en direction du
soudan l'onu en la décision de libérer
plusieurs ministres est intervenue après
une conversation téléphonique entre le
général albert année le patron de l'onu
antonio guterres est l'avait exhorté à
libérer les responsables arrêtés à
restaurer aussi d'urgence le
gouvernement civil est ce que vous voyez
un lien de cause à effet avec cris
makoun de gomis
oui
parce que l'onu peut se permettre étant
donné que beaucoup d organisations
travaillent au soudan et soutiennent le
soudan et le fonds monétaire
international
aussi à le levier financier qui permet
aujourd'hui aussi de pouvoir mettre la
pression sur le régime même place en ce
moment en essayant peut-être de gym et
sur la question de la dite désolée le
sedan est très endetté avait 60
milliards qui doivent aux familles et le
lieu peut prendre et c'est peut-être des
sanctions sur les militaires ça s'arrête
là mais cela ne viendra pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on voit très bien
ce qui se passe dans la sous région par
exemple la crise en ethiopie la crise
débarrasse de la renaissance éthiopienne
qu'aujourd'hui
est très tendu qui te met en cause comme
on appelle les relations entre le soudan
et l'egypte l'egypte et l'ethiopie et on
a bien on a vu que aussi l'ethiopie
était très présente et parfois même
l'acteur principal de la première
négociation entre les militaires et les
civils pour arriver à cette transition
aujourd'hui les turbines est pris dans
ce jeu là et on va très bien
qu'aujourd'hui celle qui mène la danse
c'est plutôt la luciole la ligue arabe
et la communauté internationale qui le
lui je ne vois pas comment aujourd'hui
une organisation peut-être mettre la
pression sur les militaires étant donné
la crise dans la sous région j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les gens
peut-être accepteront que les militaires
prennent le pouvoir trop longtemps sans
trop les déstabiliser à cause de la
situation dans la sous région et comment
lg la population louis keumayou
aujourd'hui le soudan semble trouver
profondément divisée entre les
militaires et les manifestants anti
putsch les partisans d'un pouvoir civil
réclame donc le rétablissement du
gouvernement déposé la fin aussi du
partage des autorités de transition avec
l'armée pour laissez donc les civils
organiser les premières élections libres
du pays les positions sont
irréconciliables entre les deux camps
non je crois que l'armée a joué très
finement dans le soulèvement qui a fait
tomber omar el béchir elle a compris
qu'elle ne pouvait pas aller contre la
population donc l accompagner dans un
premier temps lors de la première phase
de la révolution ce qui a permis de
renverser omar el béchir puis là elle
comprend que si elle lâche complètement
le pouvoir les civils risquent de lui
retirer tous les pouvoirs dont elle
dispose or c'est une armée qui est très
puissante
ce soit au niveau des moyens financiers
ou que ce soit au niveau des relations à
l'international les militaires soudanais
les hauts gratte et soudanais dispose
aujourd'hui d'un faisceau de relations
très importants qui peuvent faire la
différence sur un bras de fer devait se
tenir sur la durée et dont il compte là
dessus mais les professionnels et les
civils de façon générale qui ont emmené
ce coup dès qu'ils ont emmené la
révolution ne vont pas lâcher prise
parce qu'il ya parti communiste des
années qui est dans la clandestinité
aujourd'hui n'est dont les idées ont
beaucoup et c'est au sein de la
population et qui fait que par moment la
population peut arriver même quand on a
l'impression qu'elle est dans l'énergie
du désespoir peut arriver à imposer son
point de vue donc cela permettra
peut-être de rectifier le coup d'état
mais je n'ai pas l'impression qu'on est
parti ou un renversement des militaires
ça va être tendu par quelques semaines
puis au fil des négociations des bruns
des brèdes pouvoir sera abandonné au
civil mais je crois pas que les
militaires ont tout abandonné parce
qu'il y va non seulement de leur pouvoir
et de leur honneur en tant que militaire
mais également de leur capacité de
survie par rapport aux entreprises
qu'ils gèrent par rapport à l'économie
qui nous ont mis sur pied pendant toutes
ces années où il était au pouvoir il y
va également de la possibilité pour eux
de se retrouver dollars devant la cour
pénale internationale en complément de
l'envoi de omar el-béchir qui devrait
répondre de ce qu' il a fait dans le
darfour et pourquoi pas dans d'autres
régions du pays quand je pense qu'il est
très difficile aujourd'hui de faire un
pronostic
la seule certitude qui peut être
aujourd'hui martelé c'est que la
population soudanaise devait rester
méfiant elle va rester mobilisés et le
bras de fer risque d'être long et il
risque surtout si l'élan de débouchés
sub n'aurait pris répression par les
militaires qui ne voudront pas appel au
cours des négociations sont en cours
actuellement des crimes commis pour
former un gouvernement le général al
ghoreir serait prêt au retour du premier
ministre en gueule
qu'est ce qu'il souhaite précisément on
évoque un gouvernement de technocrates
oui le général juan veut se débarrasser
de ses adversaires politiques depuis
deux semaines c'est l'exigence même des
militaires s'étaient ça les civils
accusent les militaires de saboter
toutes les actions quant à la réforme de
l'état comptera c'est que les civils
puissent se répandre le pouvoir sur les
militaires dans le domaine comme un
monsieur qui me l'a dit parce que les
militaires l'armée c'est un état dans
l'état ils ont décollé à la main sur
l'économie ils ont le contrôle des
renseignements ils ont le contrôle de la
violence militaire ils ont tous et
comment les civils que vous voulez
déconstruire et effacer tout ce qui
émane de l'ancien régime font
qu'aujourd'hui sont amenés a aussi
touché les intérêts de ces militaires
donc finalement se retrouve dans une
situation d'équilibré politique très
très précaire et que chaque élément est
capable de déstabiliser c'est cet
équilibre là et ça ne va pas tenir
longtemps aujourd'hui si al brown
demandent un nouveau gouvernement ce
n'est pas parce qu'il n'est pas d'accord
avec les civils c'est parce que ce
gouvernement qui est composé de la
société civile qui est en train d
aujourd'hui mais de la commission de
transparence et de lutte contre l'ancien
régime qui sont en train de toucher tous
les intérêts de ces militaires qui
veulent ramener les forces
d'intervention rapide au sein de l'armée
aujourd'hui celui qui a refusé ces
militaires là qui veulent aussi mettre
la main sur tout le site est satisfait
de commandement militaire m le civil au
dessus de l'armee les institutions au
dessus de commandement militaire et ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les militaires
ne veulent pas donc quand ils disent
tenir nos craintes ça veut dire qu'ils
veulent des des ministres c'est
justement ce juste pour travailler
uniquement sur le domaine administratif
n'est pas toucher aux intérêts des
militaires merci beaucoup on suivra
évidemment l'évolution de la situation
au soudan avec intérêt merci
à tous les deux un tel crime d'un couple
kun de gomis chercheur associé au groupe
afrique de l'ipc et louis keumayou
président du club de l'information
africaine